a remarkable trial nearly 60 years in
the making unfolded in South Texas
former priest John feit was charged with
murdering a young woman who went to
church to give a confession back in 1960
prosecutor says it took so long to bring
fight to court because the Catholic
Church conspired with local authorities
to cover up this crime 48 hours has been
covering Irene Garza's case for years
now Richard Schlesinger as a story of
the young woman whose murder nobody
could forget here's a preview this is a
case and you're gonna find out that the
man who did this is John feit prosecutor
Mike Garza is not part of Irene Garza's
family but the story of her 1960 murder
has been part of the history of McAllen
Texas for generations kind of grew of
legend about a girl that you know went
to confession and you know never left
Irene was accomplished and admire she
went to college graduate school and
became a schoolteacher she went to
church regularly and that's where she
was last seen following a massive search
her body was discovered in a canal she
had been beaten sexually assaulted and
suffocated police had grown suspicious
of the 27 year old priest when he said a
view finder found at the crime scene was
his fight also gave different accounts
about that night and he had some
injuries from the night Irene
disappeared scratches that ran
vertically down his hands and on the top
of his arms despite the evidence the
case grew cold years passed there were
rumors that some type of deal had been
made between the church and authorities
but there was never definitive proof
until now says the prosecutor the state
calls Daryl Davis Daryl Davis is one of
the key witnesses he was a television
reporter at the time of Irene's murder
and he says there was an off-the-record
meeting with the then DA
Robert Lattimore he said we know that
father feit killed Irene Garza and the
church knows that he killed Irene Garza
he said the church is going to put him
in a monastery for disturbed or troubled
priest and he will be kept there for the
rest of his life
you won't hear evidence of corruption
what you will hear is lack of probable
cause defense attorney Rene Flores
believes John feit was never prosecuted
because of a lack of evidence not a
conspiracy no there wasn't enough
evidence then mr. Schlesinger joins us
at the table good morning Richard
morning that little old guys sitting at
the table an hour would be hard for the
jury to make the connection but that was
what the prosecution was really worried
about because if you look at I mean
looks like everybody's grandfather and
they're trying to paint him as a really
horrible killer what's the new evidence
well there's there's a bunch of new
evidence the most interesting one is a
letter that they found in just a stack
of documents that they didn't expect to
find which they're calling the
prosecution's calling a smoking gun they
say that it proves a conspiracy between
the church and the authorities at the
time to cover this whole thing up get
this guy out of town and move on in a
monastery he did he ended up in a series
of monasteries we'll talk about that in
the in the in the story of course
tomorrow
they sort of shuffled them around as was
the the practice back then but he got
married right he got married he had kids
he's a grandfather and again you look at
him and it's hard hard to see him but
I'll bet the car as a family doesn't
feel that way
they do not I mean this then that's a
great part of their stories persistence
of that family they stuck with this for
almost 60 years that's right thank you
very much for their